Unia Europejska dla mnie
to kilka bardzo ważnych wartości
to bezpieczeństwo
to wspólnota i wolność
jeżeli polska jest w unii europejskiej
i Unia Europejska jest silna i zjednoczona
to dla NAS to dobrze
jeżeli polska jest w unii europejskiej
jesteśmy w tej rodzinie unii europejskiej
to nie musimy się bać i drzeć o życie naszych bliskich
dlatego kluczowe jest to
aby tego 9. czerwca zagłosować na lewice
bo lewica stoi zawsze za tymi
którzy są z tyłu
o których się nie dba
bo lewica zawsze mówi o tych najsłabszych
pamiętajcie również idąc do urn wyborczych
wtedy kiedy będziecie głosować
że demokracja
że wolność i to
że polska jest w unii europejskiej
nie jest Dane raz na zawsze
widzimy co się dzieje teraz na świecie
widzimy te siły brunatne
siły radykalno konserwatywne
które chcą wysadzić unię europejską
i chcą ją Po prostu popsuć
my jako lewica jesteśmy gwarancją tego
żeby to się nie udało
my jako lewica zrobimy wszystko
aby polki polacy nie byli zmanipulowani przez tych
którzy mówią jasno i wyraźnie
że chcą polskę z unii europejskiej wyprowadzić
lewica mówi tak dla unii europejskiej
lewica mówi nie
dla wszystkich brynatnych sił w europie i w polsce
którzy chcą NAS z unii europejskiej wyprowadzić